it's great to be joined today by Sarah
Kenzi or a journalist who focuses on
politics the economy and media she's a
regular contributor to The Globe and
Mail you wrote this great article Sarah
in the correspondent called our fate was
sealed long before November 8th relating
of course to the election of Donald
Trump on November 8th let me just first
get a general sense from you what did
you mean by that what suggested to you
that the fate was sealed prior to the
election oh I was talking about
structural problems in the United States
that predate the election and that were
exacerbated by the campaign's during the
election in particular I was talking
about race racism white mob violence you
know conspiracy theories attacks on
freedom of the press the allure of
demagoguery you know all these sort of
things that we've seen emerging during
the Trump campaign when I wrote it
most people thought that that Clinton
was going to win the election I was
always less sure of that
despite the polls because you know I
live in Missouri and I was witnessing
what was happening around me and I saw
these these structural trends in action
and so you know I kind of felt like
either way whether Trump won or whether
Clinton won we were going to be dealing
with potential violence with racist
violence white mob violence hate crimes
and that's indeed what happened after
Trump won the only question in my mind
was whether the sorts of crimes would be
sanctioned by the incoming
administration as I do believe they are
by Trump or whether they would be
opposed as I think they would have been
under Clinton so let's dig into that a
little I mean I'd love to hear what what
your thoughts are in terms of the
sanctioning because on paper you know
Donald Trump gave this insanely tepid
pleasestop type of comment I think
during his first 60 minutes interview
when he was told about the violence that
that was taking place at the same time
we are seeing the selection to Donald
Trump's cabinet and advisors of
individuals with sort of spotty past
with regard to everything from race
relations to understanding sort of the
the real
differences between different
socio-economic classes in the United
States give me a sense of what you're
seeing from Trump that you would sort of
call sanctioning of that type of
violence or discrimination well I could
just you know to go to the points that
you just made Trump has the opportunity
to call out you know racism bigotry
xenophobia anti-semitism all the things
that we've seen happening in a very
forceful way and you know I know
personally if someone were running
around the country screaming my name and
then spray-painting swastikas are
beating up little Muslim children you
know I would be worried about that I'd
be personally offended by that and if I
were in a position of power I would
certainly do all I could to stop that in
order to protect people he doesn't seem
to want to do that protecting American
people it's not a priority for him and
so he's been you know very passive he's
letting it happen I think he knows that
you know it helps to have this kind of
mob response should something go wrong I
don't think that the people doing this
are really representative of most Trump
supporters but I do think that Trump has
an obligation when people are committing
acts of violence in his name to call
them out but then you look at the
cabinet you know you look at the
selection of people like Jeff Sessions
for example who has a long history of
racism or Michael Flynn you know and
generally speaking a cabinet that in
particular is very anti-muslim it's very
Islamophobic and then you look at you
know Trump's own campaign with
endorsements by the KKK and by you know
other white supremacists extremists who
he never really denounces and who have
certainly helped his cause and
contributed to him I don't think he has
any interest in stopping this he's
aligned even with foreign white
supremacists abroad with a growing
movement including people like Nigel
Faraj Vladimir Putin who has hosted
white supremacist in Russia for training
and guidance so I think that this is
something he wants sometimes he's pretty
overt about it most of the time he just
kind of tries to dodge the issue or make
it seem like it it's not a foremost
importance to him but it's certainly
beneficial to him and I don't see him it
had you know honoring that
moral obligation or presidential
obligation to protect vulnerable
citizens who are the victims of these
crimes in a second I want to dig in a
little bit to the anti-semitism aspect
of this but before we do that based on
the the cabinet picks and advisors
you've seen so far I think that there's
sort of an implicit sense when we see
the past statements of many of these
individuals you mentioned Jeff Sessions
you mentioned Flynn etc there's a sort
of sense that this is not going to be
good for marginalized groups but I'm
curious what you would see in terms of
the actual governmental actions that
might be taken by these in these
individuals in terms of policy what
potentially is most concerning to you
and by which cabinet member I mean we
could look at Jeff Sessions and the war
on drugs for example we could look at
Ben Carson and housing policy but what's
most concerning to you I mean everything
is concerning to me and the reason I say
everything is because I think it's
connected I think Trump's goal is maybe
a little bit different than his advisors
but Trump's goal is to build a
kleptocracy that's going to you benefit
his family that's going to strip the
country down for parts and use it to
benefit his his own personal finances
and wealth and that's been going on this
whole time so I think that that's you
know what what's in it for Trump I think
that the cabinet has other objectives in
mind I think that some of this is
extending that you know he's built a
cabinet of billionaires of Finance ears
of you know oh we Silicon Valley people
backing him you know of media empires
like Breitbart backing him you know all
of whom are gonna want a piece of this
pie and so that goes hand in hand but
then you have to sort of connect that
desire for personal wealth you know that
kleptocratic desire with an attack on
civil liberties and civil rights and I
think that you know I suppose
marginalized people it's a good way to
put it because it's a very broad
category in terms of whose rights I
think will be taken away you already see
a clamp down on voter rights you know
you saw that this year for black
Americans many of whom struggled to vote
but but couldn't under new voter ID laws
you
the plans for a Muslim registry that's
something I'm very worried about you
know some people blow it off but they've
shown every indication that they want to
follow through as I said it's a
uniformly you know anti-muslim cabinet
and if you look at the history of what
happens when you start a registry
generally it leads to camps and often to
ethnic cleansing and there have been
many attacks on Muslims since the Trump
campaign launched so I think you'll
you'll have both sanctioned and
unsanctioned forms of violence you've
seen anti-semitic attacks a lot of you
know Jewish journalists have been
attacked you know by Trump fans
throughout the campaign and often you
know very hostile and frightening ways
you know I'm trying to think of a group
that won't be hurt you know Mike Pence
this is a terrible person for gays and
lesbians you know you'll see attacks on
abortion rights which will affect women
you'll see attacks on you know even the
rights of children they want to take
away the ability of kids to get you know
breakfast and lunch in in title one
schools so you know I really don't think
that and also the elderly if you want to
go into Medicare Medicaid like I don't
think there's a group that is going to
not be hurt by this except for you know
the most privileged wealthy elite group
of white men I think even you know
there's this sort of myth of the Trump
voter as a struggling working-class
white man I don't think that myth is
really borne out and voting data you
know they're definitely white people but
of all different classes but I think
they will be heard as well you know the
folks in Missouri where I live who voted
for him I think well already you know
they will be hurt like what he did with
Boeing yesterday which is a big provider
of employment in st. Louis
you know it's potentially very harmful
for folks who may have voted for him so
basically you know we're all in trouble
when the president's main interest is
himself and he's devoid of conscience
and his administration is as well and is
you know flipping almost in their
treatment of marginalized and vulnerable
people then we're in deep trouble as a
country so our last thing I want to
touch on and next week we're going to
have a former neo-nazi to comment on
this with regard to the anti-semitism
aspect of everything that that's been
going on you know we've seen this
support of Trump from of white
nationalists former
kkkv like we've not seen for a
presidential candidate in a very long
time why do you think they're giving him
a pass on the reality that he has a
Jewish daughter a Jewish son-in-law that
clearly is a very close and trusted
adviser Jewish grandchildren in how are
how are these individuals rationalizing
that away in their support for Trump I
mean I think that they see Trump is the
key to a bigger goal and so they're
willing to overlook that
especially since Jared Kushner is a key
player in bringing the school for it as
it's Sheldon Adelson and other Jewish
backers of Trump you know I think it's
it's really unfortunate you can just
judge a person by their actions and not
their affinities and when Jewish
journalists and Jewish citizens are
being attacked then there's a moral
obligation to speak up against that so I
don't think it's good enough to say Oh
Trump can't be anti-semitic or his team
can't be anti-semitic because he happens
to have you know a Jewish son-in-law and
a daughter who converted to Judaism
they're not doing anything as Jews to
stop these sorts of attacks on fellow
Jews and I think that that is you know
what you should look at and judge
because just like Trump they could be
doing a lot to stop this to stop this
kind of hateful rhetoric to denounce
groups like the Ku Klux Klan and you
know to denounce other anti-semitic
groups and they're not doing it so it
just shows it's not a priority for them
and I think that's very unfortunate
we've been speaking with Sarah Kenzie or
we started talking about her article our
fate was sealed long before November 8th
but she's written more since then as
well and I encourage you to check out
her work Sarah thanks so much for
joining me today thank you thank you for
having me